Jeff mizanskey was a dead man sentenced
to life without the possibility of
parole because of three felony
convictions all nonviolent marijuana
related offenses mizanskey three strikes
selling a small amount of pot to a
relative possessing less than three
ounces in his home and driving a friend
to a motel to buy pot from an undercover
officer that's it no guns no sales to
children for those offenses he got life
but thanks to the efforts of his lawyer
the ACLU and the Missouri drug reform
group show me cannabis governor jay
Nixon commuted mizanskey sentence which
allowed him to win parole last week he
walked out of prison a free man
for the first time in 21 years three
weeks ago you said the first thing you
want to do is get some hay it's like
walking on air what do you think your
parents would say right now Oh they'd be
up there I'm sure they're up there watch
the smiling right now they know the
injustice that I had to go through
was cruel and unusual it's a shame
there's people in here that are in here
for molesting children and I've seen
them come go and come again and go
that's really what hurt me mark jeff has
repeatedly stated that he is very
committed to continuing to work with us
to end marijuana prohibition and that's
exactly what this is about it's not just
the fact that Jeff mizanskey should have
not have been sentenced to life without
parole should not have served 21 years
in prison no one should go to jail or
prison for even one day for marijuana
offenses and I'm talking about people
who grow marijuana and people who sell
marijuana to other adults that is the
position of show me cannabis of normal
of the ACLU and of a majority of the
American people mm I my wife and I were
the subjects of a paramilitary style
home invasion and that sort of thrust us
into drug law I found activism
I think Jeff mizanskey story embodies
how the drug war has failed it's a moral
failure the war on drugs ruins lives
fails to keep people safe and enriches
the cartels and cost taxpayers money
thank you all for coming
now I think everybody's don't watch and
dollar cookies and bacon eggs jeff
mizanskey admits he made mistakes but
three nonviolent marijuana arrests
robbed him of a third of his life
because Missouri's three strikes law
removes all sentencing discretion from
judges the law that essentially ended
mizanskey life was repealed effective
next January in a large part because
mizanskey --zz case demonstrated the
inhumanity of one-size-fits-all
mandatory minimum sentencing rules
passed at the peak of drug war hysteria
according to the ACLU more than 3,200
people in the United States continued to
serve life sentences without parole for
nonviolent offenses 79% of these are for
drug-related crimes including marijuana
for his part mizanskey says he's looking
forward to being with his family getting
back to work and devoting the rest of
his life to helping people avoid the
same nightmare that was his existence
just a few days ago